foreign
defending Europe from Attack
delivering support during covid and on
display for the king the UK's Armed
Forces play a crucial role in National
life yet Sky News can reveal that high
inflation and Rising costs have tipped
some into crisis an internal analysis by
military chaplains said the cost of
living had hit morale across the Royal
Air Force last year an anonymous quote
in the report read the food bank is
popular a footnote then added Food Bank
use is reported across a majority of
units but nowhere is yet reporting
widespread use single figures per unit
of families utilizing food banks is a
working estimate
a food bank has been set up here at Raf
coningsby in Lincolnshire originally it
was intended to collect donations from
aviators to give to civilians in the
area but A source told me RAF Personnel
are using it as well
a second report written last year by
officials here said the cost of living
crisis is severely affecting Personnel
at coningsby and this will ultimately be
reflected at all other defense
establishments the paper said some
people were having to decide whether to
buy food or fuel
what would really help service Personnel
here at Raf coningsby and across the UK
is a decent pay rise for military unlike
most public sector workers aren't
allowed to go on strike for better
conditions instead they're the ones that
are called upon to fill in for others
that do take industrial action
the armed forces are waiting for this
year's pay rise an announcement that has
been delayed when it comes it will be
welcomed but it almost certainly won't
be enough
the head of a group that represents RAF
family said this was an opportunity for
the government to show how much they
value their military they don't expect a
huge pay rise but some sort of
recognition of the cost of living crisis
and them understanding that and
therefore flagging to Personnel they are
values
a spokesperson for the RAF said the food
bank at Raf coningsby was not set up by
the RAF for its personnel and the RAF
offers a range of support such as
welfare officers who can offer Financial
advice and access to fuel grants and
hardship funds provided by the RAF and
supporting Charities and associations
a senior Minister said no one in the RAF
army or navy should have to use food
banks I know that defense ministers will
be concerned about your reports will
want to investigate and will want to do
everything possible to make sure that
our men and women in uniform are
properly looked after
people don't join the military to get
rich but they do leave if they're not
paid enough
Deborah Haynes Sky News